un avance en la estancada crisis
migratoria en la frontera chileno
peruana las autoridades chilenas
confirmaron la llegada el domingo de un
vuelo privado de repatriación procedente
de Venezuela confirmar la llegada de un
avión venezolano
al aeropuerto de arica para recoger a un
grupo bastante importante de migrantes
que están justamente varados en la
frontera migrantes venezolanos desde
hace varias semanas cientos de migrantes
están varados en el punto fronterizo
cuando trataban de cruzar a Perú debido
a que las fuerzas de seguridad peruanas
les niegan el tránsito por su territorio
O sea que algunos intentaron cruzar a la
fuerza generando roces diplomáticos
entre lima y Santiago algunos migrantes
se resignan a volver a su nación de
origen
con los venezolanos
empezaron a buscar Entonces ahora yo
nunca he estado preso en mi país y aquí
voy a estar preso por trabajar
Simplemente porque uno no tiene papeles
Entonces no no Es lógico decidido y
decidirme Exactamente para Venezuela O
sea la precaria situación en la frontera
otros se niegan a subirse en uno de los
vuelos humanitarios y buscan seguir su
camino hacia el sueño americano a mí no
me sirve el volumen humanitario porque
yo voy a Estados Unidos Mi destino es
otro y no puedo ir prácticamente como ir
allá obligada a estar allá a morirme de
hambre en Venezuela la operación forma
parte del programa Retorno a la patria
impulsado por el gobierno venezolano no
se descartan más vuelos en los próximos
días y por el momento es el único
corredor humanitario pero no una
solución definitiva